SCP-096 versus SCP-3166. Who comes out
on top between the brutalizing Shy Guy
and the horrific, lasagna-filled
Garfield-creature? Let’s find out.
SCP-3166 is a creature resembling a mascot
costume of the character Garfield that
attacks critics of the franchise through severe
bodily harm or the force-feeding of lasagna.
In a theoretical test between the two anomalies,
Garfield creator Jim Davis would accidentally see
a tiny fraction of SCP-096’s visage. SCP-3166
would manifest to ensure that nothing happened
to the Garfield strip, potentially stopping 096
. On the other hand SCP-096 has the durability
to withstand high-grade Foundation equipment,
with striking speed to match. SCP-3166 couldn’t
defend itself against such a fast and powerful
opponent, no matter how much lasagna it tried
to shove down the Shy Guy’s throat. Sorry
Garfield, looks like it’s a Monday for you.